meanwhile the US military getting called
upon now during this pandemic crisis to
help the American people a group you
might not be thinking about the who are
standing by and ready to help are the
nation's veterans in our next group is
our next guest excuse me works for a
group who wants to make sure the call is
heard he's the executive director of the
call of duty endowment dan Goldenberg
he's also a retired US naval captain has
a reserve naval captain excuse me Dan he
has more than 27 years of military
service under his belt dan I want to ask
you first you say that our nation's
veterans are uniquely qualified to help
during this pandemic tell us about what
they can do
hi Gillian thanks well you can see from
the president's actions with the mercy
and the comfort and and calling upon the
inactive reserve that the kinds of
skills that we need right now during
this time of crisis are in with within
the military be it communication supply
chain of course medical these are folks
who can reply to a crisis make order out
of chaos these are the kind of skills
that our country needs right now
companies can't obviously you know hire
the military but they certainly can hire
veterans who have these skills at this
time to help with the needs that we face
as a nation right now so we have these
nationwide hotspots now we have the you
know the problems the consequences
wrought by the pandemic and then we have
this group of presumably thousands maybe
tens of thousands of American veterans
who are able-bodied looking for work how
do we bridge the gap and make sure that
some of the right folks are in the right
place at the right time yeah well first
of all a couple weeks ago the biggest
problem we were looking at in employment
was underemployment people working below
their skill sets making less money
because of it and that hit vets
especially hard now just in the last two
weeks as we've surveyed our grantees who
last year placed 11,000 veterans and
jobs they've seen a 59 percent increase
in demand for veterans asking for help
so it's all about yeah it's just
incredible
it's going to get worse before it gets
better the good news is those veterans
out there they have these skills that
are needed right now
you know this crisis is an opportunity
to cut the red tape that's prevented
corpsman and medics and military truck
drivers the most some of the most
unemployed veterans from getting jobs we
need to cut that red tape if you can
patch someone together
who's badly injured in Afghanistan you
shouldn't have to come home and start
over recertifying to ride in the back of
an ambulance or if you can drive a rig
through the Khyber Pass you should be
able to drive it on a high ten we need
to cut this red tape and put these folks
to work and we're well positioned that
the Call of Duty Endowment to help with
that so it sounds like a no-brainer when
you lay it out that way one of the
things the administration's doing now as
president Trump signed this executive
order yesterday where he's essentially
authorizing the Defense Department to
bring back former troops and some
National Guard's folks to try and help
ease the burden that the country is
undergoing right now does that kind of
get us some of the way there well look
it's just an emblematic of the
incredible skill sets and resources the
military brings to bear so I think it's
smart obviously bringing the comfort to
New York and the mercy here to LA that
brings those skills right there but you
know for employers who are what many
folks are cutting back hours and laying
off many other industries need help you
know obviously supply chain especially
medical to be able to connect with these
resources in the in the veteran
community is really helpful it's very
important for the inactive reserves that
they're being used carefully that we're
not robbing Peter to pay Paul folks who
are doing important for instance medical
jobs right now aren't taken away from
those too
you know shift to different areas when
they're already doing good but the
bottom line is there's lots of veterans
out here right now and we can help them
if folks go to call of duty endowment
org slash higher honor we can help both
veterans and employers get matched up
with veterans with those great skill
sets and employers who need them right
now
a quick final question for you Dan what
do you hear about these two ships that
are you know making their way across
entry 1 of 1 about to head out from
Norfolk Virginia to New York City
friends and colleagues who've served on
them or been on board can you tell us
anything about what they're like well
they're just incredibly capable they're
USNS ships so you have these civilian
government GS crews who run them and
you've got a military the crew in terms
of the medical support staff and they're
incredible a thousand beds on each one
of them incredibly capable with
operating rooms and isolation facilities
they're ready to go obviously their
purpose is to take the load off the non
infected patients so that the hospitals
on land can have more capacity to help
those and greatest need with kovat 19 so
these crews are going to do it for not
just a absolutely fantastic job well Dan
Goldenberg of the call of duty and down
Minh thank you so much for joining us
today thanks for your service for folks
at home who are watching if you're an
employer and you're interested in hiring
a veteran if you have a friend or a
neighbor who is a veteran looking for
work go to the call of duty endowment
org and check out the organization's
work